hey guys it is between both much today
my name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching games but nice first off that
dragon age inquisition DLC is out as
expected and here's what 15 if your
hard-earned dollars will buy you the
jaws of hack on expansion pack will have
you discover the fate of the last
Inquisitor and the powerful dragon he
hunted the DLC takes place in the
wilderness populated by the Avar hunters
as well as within an ancient to venta
fortress there will be new enemies
equipment and a brand new boss battle
jaws of hack on is out on pc and xbox
one now and will presumably make its way
to ps4 before too long and jiggin watch
the trailer on gamespot now witcha dev
said a project red are really serious
about their facial hair with the news
that which agrees protagonist guralt
will have his beard grow over time
throughout the game so the project revs
me help lots of guy levski told
Eurogamer the beard grows as time passes
and when guralt moves between locations
the beard has several states and these
states determine its length the longest
is really long but it's not Gandalf long
the dev hub confirmed however that when
you apply the witcher threes free beard
and hair style pack the beard growing
will stop so you can keep girls around
just the way you like him the devil
previously referred to girls as eight
relatively handsome men so let's hope
there witcha promises are as impressive
as their understatements youtube may
have failed to a quiet which last year
but now it seems they're taking matters
into their own hands by relaunching
their own live streaming platform a
source has suggested to the daily diets
that the service will be driven by
gaming and esports youtube already has a
live streaming platform but google have
done little to promote it or utilize it
to its full potential allegedly youtube
has already started to amass a team of
50 engineers with expertise industry
industry it's expected that YouTube
could be making an official announcement
on its updated streaming platform in a
few months at least three let me know
down in the comments of you think
YouTube has a snowball's chance in hell
in competing with twitch as why or why
not you can have to gain spot we've got
news on Nintendo's upcoming console and
borderlands one coming to correction
that is all the good stuff that I wanted
to tell you about today be sure let me
know what you cared about and we'll
catch the same time tomorrow